>> MARK: DEMOCRATS HAVE TOTAL
CONTROL OF GOVERNMENT IN
NEW YORK STATE.
SO NATURALLY, THEY SAY SATURDAY
HANUKKAH STEPPING ATTACK WAS
VOLT OF PRESIDENT TRUMP YOU'RE
THE PRESIDENT HAS A JEWISH
SON-IN-LAW AND SPEAKS WELL OF
JEWISH AMERICANS CONSTANTLY.
HE MOVE THE U.S. EMBASSY TO
JERUSALEM, BUT ACCORDING TO
BILL de BLASIO COMMITTEE AS
HIS HATEFUL SPEECH THAT CAUSE
THIS ATTACK.
>> IT IS NOT A TIME FOR A
PARTISAN DISCUSSION, BUT IT IS A
TIME TO SAY, SOME OF THE MOST
HATEFUL SPEECHES EMANATING
WASHINGTON, D.C.
WHAT WE NEED OUR PRESIDENT TO DO
IS BE A UNIFIER, A CALMING,
POSITIVE VOICE REMINDING US OF
WHAT WE HAVE IN COMMON AS
AMERICANS.
THAT IS WHAT PRESIDENTS BOTH
DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS HAVE
DONE FOR GENERATIONS.
WE HAVE MISSED THAT.
AND THE HATEFUL SPEECH, EVEN IF
IT IS NOT INCITING SPECIFIC
VIOLENCE, LET'S FACE IT.
WE HAVE SEEN THESE VIOLENT
FORCES EMBOLDENED.
>> Mark: YEAH, THAT DOESN'T
REALLY PLAY HERE.
GOVERNMENT ANDREW CUOMO SPENT
HIS TENURE IN OFFICE DEMONIZING
PRO-LIFERS AND SUPPORTERS OF THE
SECOND AMENDMENT WITH THE SAME
POINT OF VIEW.
>> WHAT SHOULD ANYONE MAKE OF
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S TWEET?
THIS IS HOW HE PLAYS TO HIS
PARTISAN BASE BY DEMONIZING
DEMOCRATS.
DEMOCRATS ARE EVIL.
DEMOCRATS ARE BAD.
DEMOCRATS HAVE LOST THEIR MIND.
THEY ARE ANTI-AMERICAN.
THAT IS HATE.
AND THEN YOU ARE SHOCKED WHEN
YOU SEE THESE EPISODES OF HATE
ALL ACROSS THE COUNTRY?
>> Mark: WHILE WE ARE
CEMENTING, RASHIDA TLAIB WHO
ONCE BLAMED WHITE PEOPLE
ATTACKED BY BLACK ISRAELITES
ALSO DECIDED TO WEIGH IN AGAINST
THE PRESIDENT.
"FOLKS DON'T SEE THE CONNECTION
WITH HIS WORK AND HOW IT IGNITES
VIOLENCE.
HE FUELS PEOPLE'S ANGER AND
MISGUIDED HATE.
INSTEAD OF LEAVING WITH
COMPASSION CAN BE SIMPLY GAS
LIGHTS AND LAUGHS ABOUT IT."
DEROY MURDOCK WITH A
CONTRIBUTING TO NATIONAL REVIEW,
AND THIS WHITE SUPREMACY IS HIM
IS REALLY RAMP ATTAINING OUT OF
CONTROL AND THE NEW YORK AREA.
>> IT IS INTERESTING.
WE LOOK AT THE PEOPLE INVOLVED
IN THE RECENT ATTACKS, AND I
KNOW WE'VE SEEN THE LAST OF
THEM, BUT MORE PLAUSIBLE THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS APPEALING TO
WHITE SUPREMACIST UNTIL WE LOOK
AT THE PEOPLE WHO ENGAGE IN
THESE SORTS OF THINGS.
TIFFANY HARRIS WHO ALLEGEDLY
WENT UP TO THREE JEWISH WOMEN,
SLAP THEM ACROSS THE FACE, AND
SAID F YOU, JEWS.
AND THEN WE HAVE GRAFTON THOMAS,
THE HANUKKAH ATTACK WHICH IS
DISCUSSING WITH A MACHETE.
HE HAPPENS TO BE BLACK AND THAT
AWFUL ATTACK IN NEW JERSEY CITY
WITH A MARKET TO SHOOT UP THAT
FACILITY AND KILL A BUNCH OF
PEOPLE.
THOSE PEOPLE FRANCINE GRAHAM AS
WELL.
SO IT IS ODD THAT YOU DON'T SEE
THE WHITE SUPREMACY SORT OF
SUSPECT IN THE ANTI-SEMITIC
ATTACKS.
>> Mark: GET REAL, DEROY.
BEFORE THE MUG SHOTS.
>> THAT MUST BE WHAT HAS
HAPPENED.
>> Mark: LISTEN, IT IS QUITE
DISGRACEFUL WHAT IS HAPPENING
HERE.
AND THE JERSEY CITY ATTACK, THE
MEDIA WERE INTERESTED IN THAT
WHEN THEY THOUGHT IT WAS SOME
GUY GOING NUTS ON.
THE MINUTE THEY FOUND OUT IT WAS
NOT HELPFUL FOR THE NARRATIVE --
>> THE WHOLE THING FELL INTO
THIS PARTICULAR ATTACK IN IT WE
WOULD NOT BE TALKING ABOUT
JERSEY CITY ATTACK.
IN THE MEDIA ARE VERY, VERY GOOD
ABOUT NOT COVERING THE NUMEROUS
EXAMPLES OF PRESIDENT TRUMP
SPEAKING ABOUT ANTI-SEMITISM.
THAT ATTACK IN CALIFORNIA,
SAN DIEGO.
HE INVITED THE RABBI, HUGGED HIM
IN PUBLIC, ASKED HIM TO GET UP
AND SAY A FEW WORDS AND BEFORE
HE DID THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP SAID
WE WILL FIGHT WITH ALL OF OUR
STRENGTH AND EVERYTHING WE HAVE
TO DEFEAT YOU ANTI-SEMITISM AND
TO CONQUER ALL HATE.
THE RABBI SAID I WOULD LIKE TO
THANK YOU MR. PRESIDENT FOR --
GUESS HOW MUCH COVERAGE THAT GOT
ON ABC, CBS, NIGHTLY NEWS
PROGRAMS?
ZERO.
IF YOU ARE A WITH ANTI-SEMITISM,
GENTILES PRO-JEWISH AND
DISTURBED ABOUT THIS, THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES,
BE COMFORTED.
WE LOVE YOU AND ALSO DON'T BE
ANTI-SEMITISM, THAT IS ABOUT
THING.
THOSE MESSAGES DON'T GET OUT AND
COVERED UP BY THE MEDIA PLAYING
IN THE HANDS OF WHITE SUPREMACY.
>> Mark: ACTUALLY, A
FASCINATING SERIES OF TWEETS BY
AARON BIEBER WHO IS A
FACT-CHECKER OF ALL THINGS AT
NBC NEWS WHO SAYS THAT THIS IS
ALL VERY "COMPLICATED RELATIONS
BETWEEN THE TWO COMMUNITIES
BETWEEN BLACKS AND ARE
COMPLICATED". BASICALLY, IF YOU
GUYS WOULD JUST PUT DOWN FOR
MACHETES, WE COULD ALL GET BACK
TO HATING TRUMP AS ONE UNITED,
HAPPY RAINBOW COALITION.
HOW LONG ARE PEOPLE GOING TO PUT
UP WITH THIS NONSENSE?
>> IT IS JUST AWFUL.
THE MEDIA NEEDS TO BE HONEST
ABOUT WHAT PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS
DONE.
HE HAD A HANUKKAH PARTY.
IF YOU ARE TRYING TO FILM HATRED
AGAINST JEWS, YOU DON'T THROW A
HANUKKAH PARTY.
YOU DON'T LET YOUR DAUGHTER,
MARRY AN ORTHODOX JEW, WHICH IS
WHAT SHE DID, AND JARED KUSHNER
THE CLOSEST ADVISOR, HATED SO
MUCH HE WOULD SAY GET OUT OF MY
WAY, GET OUT OF MY FAMILY,
GOODBYE.
BUT EXACTLY THE OPPOSITE.
JARED KUSHNER AND Ivanka Trump
>> Mark: BUT ACTUALLY
SOMETHING CREEPY AND WICKED
ABOUT GOVERNORS AND MAYORS AND
CONGRESSMEN MISREPRESENTING.
BASICALLY, BILL de BLASIO, HE
EVEN DOES THIS KIND OF MAYOR OF
"SESAME STREET" STUFF WHERE
HATERS KNOW HOME IN OUR CITY,
12-YEAR-OLD INTERN.
ALL WE HAVE, HE ACTUALLY BLAMES
IT ON PEOPLE WHO HAVE NOTHING TO
DO WITH THE EVENT.
HOW LONG WILL PEOPLE PUT UP
WITHOUT?
>> I LIVE IN NEW YORK CITY AND
WE ARE SICK AND TIRED OF
BILL de BLASIO.
NEVER POINTING THE FINGER AT
HIMSELF.
HE DOES SO IN THIS CASE AS WELL.
HE IS SAYING HOMELESSNESS IS THE
FAULT OF PRESIDENT TRUMP AS
WELL.
>> Mark: OKAY.
>> AND SOME SHORTAGE OF HANUKKAH
CANDLES IN THIS COUNTRY.
>> Mark: THAT IS HIM,